Most people know the Hulk as a gigantic green
guy who's incredibly strong, super tough,
and can maybe jump really, really far.
Pretty straightforward, right?
But it turns out that in the comics, the Hulk
actually has a lot of weird bonus abilities
as well.
Here's a look at some superpowers most people
don't know the Hulk has.
Beyond sucker punching, that is.
Hulk sees dead people
Weirdly enough, it turns out the Hulk can
detect the spectral realm, and even interact
with it, allowing him to see ghosts as well
as Dr. Strange's astral form.
Although it's never been made official, it's
been suggested that the Hulk gained the ability
to see ghosts because Bruce Banner fears his
abusive father might haunt him.
Being afraid of ghosts makes sense, since
clearly the Hulk's got nothing to fear in
the physical world.
"Is that all you got?"
Hulk has brain-shield
There's nothing worse for a superhero than
being mind-controlled by an evil telepath
or demon.
Luckily for the Hulk, he's actually naturally
resistant to psychic attack in the comics.
While this ability doesn't have 100 percent
success rate, it has allowed him to fight
off psychic intrusions from the likes of Xemnu,
Mentallo, and even Professor X.
Why the Hulk is resistant to psychic abilities
is unclear, though it might have to do his
multiple personality disorder.
Still, if you're going to mess with the Hulk's
brain, your best bet is just flying in his
ear.
Hulk phone home
Bruce Banner may have been born in Dayton,
Ohio, but the Hulk was created in New Mexico,
something he is constantly reminded of thanks
to a powerful homing instinct that continually
draws him back to the deserts of the southwest.
It's later revealed by an evil future version
of the Hulk named Maestro that his ghost is
what's been summoning Hulk to the bomb site
so that he can absorb enough gamma radiation
through Hulk's body to be reborn.
Seems legit!
Hulk absorb and expel energy
The Hulk was born when Bruce Banner absorbed
way too much gamma radiation, so it actually
kind of makes sense that the Hulk is able
to absorb and even control gamma energy to
a limited degree.
He's used this handy ability on several occasions,
even deflecting gamma rays like a mirror while
battling the Avengers.
Don’t mess with the Hulk!
roar
Hulk very, very healthy
Like Wolverine, the Hulk has a superhuman
healing factor, which allows him to recover
from injuries and fight off diseases.
But he's also aided by that crazy gamma radiation,
which tends to just flat out kill off any
parasites or germs that are stupid enough
to attempt infecting the Hulk.
Aside from giving him a clean bill of health,
his super-immunity also helps the Hulk detoxify
when he's been poisoned, something Bruce probably
appreciates when he decides to tie one on
the night before.
"Sounds amazing."
"He's also a huge dork.
Chicks dig that."
Hulk is super adaptable
If you've ever seen the Hulk jump up out of
Earth's atmosphere or walk along the bottom
of the ocean, you probably noticed that he
has certain advantages over normal people.
It's clear that he doesn't need to breathe
and is impervious to the vacuum of space.
But why?
Well, thanks to some research from SHIELD,
we know that the Hulk's gamma mutation allows
him to further mutate and adapt to any environment
he's exposed to.
Probably explains how he managed to walk away
after this:
Hulk has super breath
Everyone knows about Superman and his super
breath.
But did you know that the Hulk also has lungs
of steel?
Not only does this make him a hit at birthday
parties, it's also a handy trick to use on
enemies, or even on random forests, like this
one that the Hulk flattened on a whim in Incredible
Hulk #273.
Apparently the Hulk isn't much of an environmentalist,
but he is a pretty big blow hard.
"Hulk like raging fire.
Thor like smoldering fire."
Hulk can punch through time and space
Just how strong is the Hulk?
Well, it turns out he's strong enough to punch
through dimensional barriers and even destroy
entire dimensions with a swing of his big
dumb fist.
Not only that, but in one story he was able
to punch his way through a time-storm, and
on another occasion he plugged a black hole
— with his butt.
You might say the Hulk has godlike powers,
except, well… he's kind of in a class all
his own.
"Puny god."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!